في عام 2016 اتصلت ممثله الافلام الاباحيه
ستورميدان بوسائل اعلام عارضه عليها بيع
قصتها حول ما قالت انها علاقه جنسيه
ربطتها في 2006 وسائل اعلام قالت ان ترامب
دفع مبلغ 130 الف دولار لتلتزم الصف خلال
فتره ترشحه عام 2016 وهذا التصرف الذي قام
به وضعه في مرمى الاتهام وسط انباء حول
اعتقاله الذي كان قد تحدث عنه قبل ايام
لكن ما الذي سيحدث اذا اعتقل ترامب في حال
تم توجيه التهامي المذكوره الى دونالد
ترامب اشار محاموه الى ان اعتقال الرئيس
السابق سيتبع اجراء متعارفا عليه وذلك
يعني ان ترامب سيمثل امام محكمه مدينه
نيويورك وستكتمل العمليه بحدز رسمي للقضيه
واخذ بصماته وتصويره الا ان الطريقه التي
سيتم فيها هذا الامر غير واضحه وستكون على
الارجح موضع مفاوضات بين مكتب مدعي عام
المقاطعه وفريق ترامب
ستتضح تفاصيل اخرى مثل موعد المحاكمه
والقيود المحتمله على السفر ومتطلبات
اطلاق سراحه بكفاله ماليه لكن ان تمت
ادانته بتهمه جنائيه فانه سيواجه حكما
بالسجن اربع سنوات كحد اقصى فيما يتوقع
خبراء قانونيون ان الاحتمال الاكثر ترجيحا
هو ان يتم فرض غرامه ماليه عليه وانه من
غير المتوقع ان يقضي اي فتره زمنيه خلف
قطبان السجن شاركونا ارائكم هل سيتم الحكم
بالسجن على تراب